Great, uh, thanks for taking
the time to see our presentation.
We are gonna be having a
conversation with Grupore
Internacional,
particularly Armando Valenzuela is
going to share
with us their transformation
process using AWS Transform4.NET.
Uh, the service, uh, was,
uh, launched, um,
a few months ago, so they started
in a fair release.
Now a event
there are a lot of launches that you have already
seen, so we are gonna go in, uh,
through those as well.
But let's hear what are, um,
Grupore's challenges regarding
their modernization efforts, right?
So this is the agenda we're gonna go
through a quick introduction. We're gonna
present a group of Tres International
what they do.
Armando is going to dive deep into their
challenges. He's gonna share with us
their transformation path, the transformation
journey regarding
all the, uh,
key lessons learned that they got
into their path while transforming
their solution.
And this is very interesting. Uh, he's going
to dive deep into the architecture, as
you know, this session is a level 200,
so expect, uh, deep, uh, technical
content and also the demonstration
of the service and benefits that it's going
to be led by,
uh, Tiago and, uh, what's,
uh, next in terms of lessons learned
and what's the,
uh, next adventure from Group of Trece.
Now who is Grupores International?
So, uh, Grupores is
a leading Mexican company. They
are, uh, focused on human
resources management,
payroll processing, and attendance control
solutions.
Uh, they have a long heritage.
Uh, they have been, uh, uh, building software
since 1991,
so you can imagine that
they have a lot of, uh, legacy code
out there. And their solution has been
evolving and during
these years. They are headquartered
in Tijuana, not so far from here,
and by 2024,
uh,
GTI as we call them, reached 68%
coverage of all Mexico's
manufacturing.
Uh, employees,
so imagine that you
are receiving your payroll and
you are working at a manufacturing sector.
You may want to receive your payments
week by week or
every 15 days.
So this is how it works for the manufacturing
sector, uh, in Mexico in particular.
And they reach more than
1200 customers
and up to 4.4
million employees,
so
they have a pretty large impact out
there. So
let me introduce Armando Valenzuela
who is the head of engineering.
Um, buenos dias, uh, bomtia
in Portuguese, right, Tiago,
and good morning everyone.
Uh, let me just introduce myself
really quickly.
I have been working in Grupores for more
than 20 years,
and, uh, I started working on
a legacy Windows and premise
applications.
Yeah, we,
I worked with Delhi in that time.
Uh, no, no shame on that.
Then I moved to working on cloud
native, uh, serverless
applications, and now I work as a part
of the architecture enablement
team that we, and we serve,
uh, multiple product development teams as
well. I
So,
uh, picture this, uh, you have
more than 4 million
of users trying to request your,
to your app,
right? They're trying to do something meaningful
with your application in a Friday
evening.
Um, customers are calling technical
support for your help.
Uh,
the product teams are really stressful,
and this application is running on
a legacy code of more than 10
years
running on a Windows being installed that doesn't escalate
as you think
or as you wish.
Well Um,
surely that is not a happy Friday
for everyone,
and that happened to us earlier
this year.
Week by week and well,
a lot of people was involved in that.
And um including an infrastructure
team and support.
And I mention this quote.
The leading sources of technical debt are architectural
choices
because it's important to remark
that migration the code to a newer
version of .net
is not the important
issue here.
You need to,
to think broader,
to not, uh, derive in a
technical debt that you're going to heritage
to your
new employees of your company in the following
years.
Right. So
this modernization approach is
something that we
think in our organization
because our mission is,
is just
experience the joy of improving lives.
And the lives that we are improving
is not just
our customers
or the employees but also
our developers.
So, with this modernization,
we could do the both things, right?
One, deliver a better service
to our end users and
also improve the developer experience
for our developers.
What challenges
do we have?
Well,
uh, basically
more than challenges, these are the pillars
that we follow in this migration.
One is stay customer centric,
right? We need,
we needed to meet scalability and
performance needs.
Sta the second one stay cost
effective
and this way.
Uh, we need to reduce the progressional
cost
and simplify the modernization and maintenance
efforts and that, and, and that's related to the,
uh, developer experience.
Also zero downtime
requirements.
This was a crucial
need. Uh, when
you migrate, uh,
a critical production workload,
yeah, you need to do it with, without
disrupting, uh, payroll operations
or customer SLAs.
OK,
let me explain
the application context.
This is a very good, very Mexican
thing
because the Mexican government
requires for every payroll,
uh, slip
to be notified
to the Mexican Tax Administration Service.
It's like the IRS but in Mexico.
So basically the process
begins
when the um payroll
manager
or administrator.
Using our HR management suites,
in this case, we have Systemares on-premises
and Revolution as a software
as a service
that it's running on AWS.
They send all the payroll
data through the uh payroll stamping
services that we provide to them.
Uh,
because, well, we have security guidelines.
I'm not allowed to explain you all
the VPCs, all the integration with
networking and such,
but I tried to, um.
Uh, explain the features that
uh payroll stamping
services provide.
Then,
after the uh
payroll managers and all the data,
then the employee through the our
self-service HR application.
The employees able to download
to get
the payroll slip
and that's.
That's a huge deal for the
employees in Mexico and I'm sure here
in the US as well,
but for legal reasons,
the
companies are
obligated to report those payroll
on time.
If that does happens, the uh
company could have some legal
issues with
with their unions or with their
employees directly.
So what it works
uh that we have here a
legacy XML PDF engine
that actually generates the the
uh PDF of the invoice,
right? And we're replacing,
we replace this service.
With a, with a lambda service practically
and this lambda has around
2 million requests,
uh,
daily
and some days on peak days
we have up to 4 million of requests.
And
for for
our services this is the most
used
endpoints.
In our office infrastructure.
OK. This
is just an overall
view
of the monolith architecture. This
is basic and elastic
pin stalk, sorry,
containerized application that runs on
two availability zones and multiple regions
as well.
And I don't want to say that uh
Beanstalk is not, is not running well.
Actually, it's running phenomenal.
But the issues that we have with beanstal is
that it doesn't increase.
Uh, the, uh,
instances as we expect,
right? It's not has the,
the,
hasn't the same velocity than a lambda.
So,
using NWS Transform,
what was the art transformation approach?
Well, I recommend to
be prepared.
And I'm not talking about the product uh
developers or engineers. I'm, I'm talking
about your code,
right? The first thing that I
suggest to do is to analyze
which projects are
the most
um
or the best candidate to migrate.
You surely need, after that,
after selecting the best project
that match your needs to uh of this migration,
you need to organize
your legacy projects.
Uh, talking about our experience,
we had a lot of dependencies,
uh,
talking about new good packages on our
solutions,
and I would like to ask
you something.
Uh, please raise your hand if you are dealing
with nougat or packages
dependencies issues late.
Yeah, just a few.
Perhaps it was just a house, but
um,
yeah,
when
our projects we had like 70
new get packages involved, some private
and some
public,
right, and we removed um
around 23 unneeded packages.
That's normal because developers
actually uh get
an add you get packages that they need and
with the uh inherited
dependencies
they uh add multiple
and unneeded naked packages,
right. That's common.
Also just to report that we
had more than 135,000
lines of code. This is lines of code
of the entire uh
um
uh suite, right?
You also need to have your, you do
test in order,
and if you don't have them, that's OK,
you can create it later, but you need to,
to have it in mind to compare
the before and after.
OK, with LBS transform,
we were able to automatically
uh migrate from 46
to .NET 8 and
AW transfers helps us to validate
most of the code.
And also the packages were updated.
But we need to take care
about the less of the 100% of the code.
There was a lot,
that there are not just a few lines,
but with the help of
ASN Q. Right?
We were able
to do some manual fixes and.
And we can run local and
functional tests
with AmazonQ now named
well now Quiro,
right? we're able to multiply
our efforts rapidly
to jump onto
uh production,
right? After
the adjustment and the
running local application,
of course we needed to build a
standalone application. The application would
uh to, to test
the transformation.
We enter in a multiple cycles of a factory,
right? We move
the packages
to the core artifact,
and I'm, I'm not talking about the new get
packages
we decouple our
application or our service and
multiple,
uh, artifacts
to be
to not create
a, a micro service
with all
the code involved, right?
There is not.
I was in a
in a session
this Monday
and and
ma'am MAM 402,
there was a cool talk and they
mentioned that
you, the thing is not to create
a shared monolith,
right, or a distributed monolith,
right? So do you, you need to
think right and decouple your code
before migrate to Yolanda.
Also, we are able to automate our builds
via CDK and called Pipeline.
And I'm going to go through
our timeline.
In a more
Explainable way.
We started this effort in April.
And we were able to transform the code
and do the manual fixes
in less than 2 weeks.
They take a little bit long
because we needed to,
to decouple the service correctly, right?
And
During this migration we were able to
replace the legacy NG server
to use code artifact CDK
and code pipeline to integrate those.
Then on the run
we don't jump directly from elastic
pistol to lambda.
We took,
uh, a step with AWS Fargate,
right, the microservices.
Firstly we tried to run
it on ECS Fargate and ran
some tests.
And it, well, in,
and the behavior was OK with uh Fargate,
but
we don't have uh we don't want
to.
Um, have more
things to administrate
or more things to do around
UCS Firegate. That's not our, our
traditional model.
We tend to use more lambdas
to, uh, our applications,
so we moved the, the,
uh, we removed the continuization
practically
and changed the project to not use,
um. An image, a docker
image for that
and uh
and we use um in a sip
model right. Uh,
but the most important issue here
is to add
X-rate
metrics,
right, uh, cloud watch,
and of course
get metrics inside of your
running application,
running service,
because
when you migrate your code,
the environment of, of the operational
environment, it's quite, it's
much different, right?
So you need to keep what is
not behaving as you expected.
Well this is a high level solution and
then simple like that
right it's an
it's a lambda the name is document generator
it's almost the same uh
all are the same buckets that
we're managing.
Uh, it has their own app database,
so we were able to decouple
the database as well
and all behaves, uh,
integrates well with the payroll stepping
service, right?
So the,
our, uh, self-service
application named Mazorden
hasn't to
change their endpoints or anything. All
it's managed
inside
this,
uh, context, right, of the
application. Right,
so what were the benefits of this
migration?
Firstly,
we could do this in a rapid way.
Uh,
when I started the conversation with you,
I said that the product teams were really
busy,
so we have to help on
that as an architecture and
enabling team.
We don't use to invest the time
on developing new things, right? We,
uh, we help the teams to
design, to organize, to,
uh, training them,
but we were help,
uh, we were able to help with this
migration,
so we calculate almost 70%
of reduction in that human
hours, right.
We saved
like 2 months of the team on manual
code testing and validation.
This, this is was not just migrating
the code, right?
We needed to also generate new
tests,
uh, new integration test,
and,
and, and such, right.
Another thing was the strategic refactoring.
The team was focused on value
driving refactoring rather than tedious
metal work
and Not
that I'm not saying that
we because we have the time we invest the
time in in architecture.
No it's the other way
we because with this product
we were able
to not just react to the problem
that we had.
Um, rapidly do the migration manually
and, and then go to production. No,
we were able to think this browser
and decouple all the monolith
for further migrations, not
just the document generation that
I explained.
Also cost savings.
We were able to reduce the infrastructure
cost by over 40%
using graviton-based lambdas.
So
we. What I'm trying to
say is that we were not just
going through the basic lambda
configuration.
In this case, the AWS AWS,
sorry, Mexico,
uh, architects team
helped us to go farther.
They, they say, hey, you can go graviton
directly and our packages.
That we are using to generate PDFs
are well tested on Windows environments.
So we were worrying about not
having the same results.
So with Amazon Q,
we,
we generate a uh more
than a couple of Python scripts
that automatically help us to validate
A B tests,
right? So
So in the run,
Uh,
we, we also eliminate
the Windows licensing costs.
That's an indirect cost that we have
on, on,
on beanstalk, right?
But so that's something
that was good for us.
Elasticity
Uh,
in, on average, we have
11.3 million
of payroll documents processed
daily.
Um, we don't
have an issue with that, with the lambda
right now.
Serial manner scaling.
Of course we were not doing
manual scaling and be install, but
we had to be aware of
what's happening on the peak days. And
then infrastructure team,
uh, did some changes on it.
So
that's something that we don't need to be careful
for now with our landda, of
course you need to follow the metrics
and, and, and, and
perhaps,
uh,
you can do some,
uh.
Um, changes in your lambda
to in case you, your
demand increase, right? But for now,
we are calculating that with the
lambda, we're OK.
Then we had 0 downtime during payroll
spikes.
This is just an example of what we
uh had running the uh
the AB testings
uh earlier this year.
And as you can see
we have the
duration
between half of a
second. Um,
during the peak,
uh, invocations,
the lambda still has
better results than
the invocations are low,
so. That's,
that's that wasn't good for us.
Lesson learned.
Well, I'm going to try
to summarize this really quickly,
as I said before.
Uh, you have, if you have a
running
legacy application.
You have the privilege to compare
with the new version,
right? And in case
you can run a task
more than once
like. We do with the payroll
slip. Right, you can
compare the results of
your legacy versus the new version,
so. That
when I talk about the uh Python scripts
that compare the PDFs basically
we did it on production
right we um.
We deploy this.
Uh, at the same time we were
delivering the PDF that we built in
Beanstalk
and at the back end we were having
the lambda
generated.
Version so we were able to compare
the uh
the SA by pixel by pixel
and text by text.
So in that way,
we were confident
that we can switch.
Gradually with a canary release,
uh,
uh, the new version
so if you are in that case, I
recommend. To do
this in case your
process cannot be executed
more than once,
of course, you can go canary always and,
and select your start users as well, so.
Otherwise
There is a win on this.
The other other thing that we learned.
In a sense,
is to adapt.
Modernization is not just code migration.
So, don't expect to just
transform and be on the other side
the next day,
right? But
also.
You need to be aware if you're going to migrate
your application with the help of Qiro.
Uh, to lambda
You need to be aware of of call
starts, provision concurrency, snapstart,
and package sites optimizations
because you're going to migrate something
that was running on a monolith and and
works perfectly because
all your singletons, your, your connections
are well oiled in
the in the production environment,
not with the lambda. With the lambda you need
to be aware of your connection pools,
your memory setups,
and your connection with.
Other services, right?
So, Uh, in
case your, your internal
developer say something that
is with being installed was faster
than lambda,
don't hesitate
and procure this in this,
uh. Uh,
this Probably
issues with cold stars
and just to have a question that I want
to ask you.
I don't know if you have many have issues with
cold stars or time slander.
Yeah, that.
Do be aware of that if you are migrating
from data
automation we achieve, uh,
fully automated validation that I
mentioned before, the patent scripts
and other kind of spreads with uh
J reader as well.
To do uh
um critical benchmarking tests.
Right. So
now let's get technical.
Back to you, David. Thank you.
That Thank
you very much Hernando. Thank you for sharing with
us your uh case. It's
pretty amazing what you have achieved in this
time. Also, if you have any
questions, you can approach to the Groupres
team that is here by the end of this session
so you can discuss it, uh, further.
Now let's get into the AWS
Transformer and how it works.
Why to modernize your applications?
That's a pretty simple question. You may
already know the answer,
but there are a lot of factors in
here. For example, Armando
mentioned we improved, uh,
uh, for example, response times of the
services we moved from elastic
beanstock
to lambdas.
So from there we can deduce
that we are gonna have
some cost optimizations.
We will, uh, as you can
see the performance improvements.
And also the scalability
having lambda for example instead of a monolith
will allow uh the teams to actually
have more manageability and
also more scalability in terms
of what they are doing and what they are
prospecting in terms of
uh application growth.
Something interesting that Armando mentioned
is that the service, the AWS transform
service moves the monolith
to actual uh microservices
in.
Uh, containers
you can deploy, for example, to transform
code to EC2 with
Linux or ECS Fargate,
but uh what Arman Armando did
and the team did
was to actually migrate
directly to a serverless architecture,
and that's possible and that's
something that maybe you don't see
in AWS transform right now but
with the integration of Qiro
and other.
Tools, it is actually possible
and it took a group of res 2 weeks
to actually reach this stage
of maturity.
So porting uh to cross-platform.net,
it's hard and it's slow and you already
know that
that's why you are here, right?
And also
the AWS transform service.
We'll take your code.
So as you can imagine, everything is gentic
now, so.
AWS transform is iggenic.
Now this week it was launched the
uh next uh generation of
AWS transform that will allow you
to have
multi-agent capacity. What does
this mean?
You're gonna be able to actually
drive at the uh modernization
process the way you like it.
So through this agent that it
was released this week
you are able to actually drive the
process of modernization maybe if you are
looking toward um
changing the architecture of your services
and only porting the code to this new
architecture you're gonna be able to do
so instead of uh actually
depending entirely on the agent capacities
to design this plan
so this is a huge improvement
compared to what we had in the past.
Also detecting incompatibilities
as Armando mentioned before, uh, they
were able to
clean their coat and they found that
23 dependencies
were just they're hanging around.
They just removed them
and the code actually
became cleaner.
Then we port the code.
The transform agent, after analyzing and
detecting incompatibilities, is
going to design a modernization plan
and what's going on here?
So the uh agent is going to
design a plan based on your source code
and projects that you want to migrate.
As humans we need to validate that
process, so we need to be involved in
this validation stage of this
modernization plan.
After having the modernization plan and porting
the code,
we are gonna be able to deploy directly
to ECS Fargate or EC2
with Linux,
and, well,
in this case, uh, it was, um,
very manual labor as Armando mentioned. They
would take like months to
do what they do in, uh, a couple
of weeks.
And uh a lot of stuff going around
in terms of how teams
will manage the uh migrated
services.
So what we are looking uh here
it's
how long projects can be shorter.
How licensing costs can be cut
and also suboptimal and net porting
quality,
so the transformation process is not
porting the code only,
it's going to find uh
fixes that can be made within your code
and it's going to recommend a code that
has
improvements in terms of quality of
the code that is being imported
and also a quality in
terms of security.
So this is very important to have in mind.
And uh well this is the
introduction to AWS Transform for .NET
that has two experiences the ID
that is the one that we are gonna
show you
today and also the web ID
both behave similarly in
terms of functionality and the agents
that are behind the service,
but, uh, you need, for example, in
the case of the uh.net porting
into the ID that is the second picture
here. The integration with
the AWS toolkit from there you
can grab the AWS transform component
and start uh your modernization.
In terms of the web
interface, you just need to connect your source
code that could be
a place, for example, in Azure
DeBop, GitHub, Gitlab, or Bitbucket,
such as in the case of
Group of trace.
And once we have that,
we have connected our code, we have integrated
Visual Studio,
we can start the process.
Of analyzing the code base,
so what's going to happen here?
These agents are going to index your
code, are going to process
uh this part.
The code is being moved to
AWS processing to actually
understand what's uh your code, how it
behaves, the dependencies it has.
And once we have completed this part.
Here came the,
here comes the transformation process.
The transformation process, again, it really depends
on a transformation plan.
And once we have this transformation plan, we
can iterate here, and this is something
new you can interact with the agent
to
actually
drive the transformation process.
And finally, the validation, the human
interloop part of every single
agentic solution.
What's the purpose here and this is,
uh, like the whole that this,
um,
this slide presents is how we can
take this .NET framework
applications
to the new
Linux.NET 8 applications
and now uh .NET 10.
This is a more deep dive, uh,
a component that I want to highlight here is
this part,
the dependencies.
For example, the analysis process is
a little bit more complex within the
service.
It really requires to analyze
code for incompatibilities.
Identified a generates a
replacement code that is going to substitute
uh your actual code
AWS transform once the transformation
is completed, is going to push
this transform code into a
version system.
It will use the version system
you connected to and
once again you need to generate a branch
to
so can the transformation
process can deposit code into that
uh branch
so we can have a full control
of how the ported code
is going to
going to be placed.
And here are two dependencies. If you
develop your nuggets yourself, you can,
uh, share those
with a double transform service so you can uh
reach this uh dependency management
controls. If no nuggets are
provided or if the service does not
find in their in its knowledge base
those uh nugget uh packages,
the service is going to try to do
the best
to actually
understand what those packages are doing,
so. Once we have done this,
we apply code modifications. We can verify
the code. It's something that didn't
go as expected. We can get
back and try again.
So this is a process that
it's usually led by,
by the developer or the architecture
team. Now,
this slide is regarding
the .NET transformation for .NET
framework.
It also will transform this
MVC Razor interfaces.
We have web forms to blazer
integration
and also take cross-platform .NET
8 and .NET 10.
So there are a couple of targets
more for this, uh, transformation that
it's going to help us,
uh, build modern .NET architectures.
And also er the
previous projects that it's wind farms and
Windows presentation
er for desktop projects, uh
hammering, for example,
and er everything else
here. For large
scale modernization you can take
uh several projects uh at one
single shot or you can choose
between all those uh.net projects
to start developing and transforming
one by one or
uh take or grab all
of your code base and start transforming
from there. Now,
the NBC race part that
is uh pretty interesting uh Costa has
been asking a lot for this one,
it's going to take and transform your
code and port it to
ASP.NET core.
And also um
Apple Store and just transformation that it's
supported as well and it's below here,
that it's going to take your word forms,
and it's going to transform into
player. So, uh, this one's
pretty new as well.
And how does it look like?
Here? Tiago is going
to share with us a demonstration
on how this works
and how to integrate into ID
to AWS transform components.
And before diving deep, er, this is just
a reminder of the connections for
code. You can connect
GitHub, Gitlab, Bitbucket, Azure
Repos, and also Amazon
S3 code for analysis.
If you don't want to actually connect your,
uh, source code repositories, you can
uh share them using,
uh, Amazon S3.
Also, the view assessment, this is a summary
report that you're gonna be able to see
when the transformation process is complete,
and also you will be able to provide
once I get the you get packages.
This could be developed internally
or this could be uh from
third parties.
Now, here, the console experience is
pretty the same,
but uh in this case, uh
we are gonna have a full support
of an agent and a chat console
that you're gonna be able to interact
with. What's the advantage of this part?
Having uh the capacity
to actually drive the modernization
efforts to a certain architecture
to a certain
way of uh coding that you have
in your companies is crucial
for uh driving the modernization
efforts you are paying attention to
and this is uh very important and
we are gonna be
reviewing this as well.
This is the integration.
Kiro is going to help us as Armando already
mentioned. They use Quiro at the last
stages. So what's the recommendation here?
Start with AWS Transform. Once
you have ported your code to
.NET 8 or .NET 10,
use Quiro to actually
improve code, make fixes
or or ports to lambda, for
example, which was
what, uh, Grupores did.
And, well, the SQL Server transformation,
maybe you are wondering uh what happens
to the databases.
Well, this is uh pretty straightforward. We
can also support uh databases
including SQL Server and manage dependencies
within your code.
How do we do that?
Here is the part before and after
the transformation.
So this is a
uh transform full stack windows
and you will have everything here
starting from your application,
your database layer,
and your virtual machine running
on Windows server.
The intention of this part of AWS
transform
is to actually modernize the
full stack.
Not just uh leave it with uh
application transformation. You can focus on that
as well if you want to keep your databases,
but if you are
managing to migrate
everything to Linux,
this is the way to go.
So
the target is to have a cross-platformNT
application, run your, uh, databases
in AuroraPostress,
and also having, uh, the infrastructure
components regarding ECS and
EC2
with Linux.
So
Let's get to the demo.
Thank you, Tiago.
Thank you, David.
Good morning.
What a great achievement Gruppores
did with uh modernization of
their application.
And today
I will demonstrate how you
can achieve the same.
My name is Chago Gonzalez.
I'm a solutions architect in AWS
and for the past 20 years, I
have, I have been developing and
modernizing applications.
Yes. So
when we,
when we talk about uh AWS
transform, as David
mentioned,
we have two options. One is the web
experience.
If you are
in a devs teams and you want to
modernize
applications in batch,
you will use the web
experience.
But if you are a developer and you want
to modernize one application at a time,
you will use.
Um, the ID version of
AWS transform.
So what I have in here.
It's the Vizo Studio,
it's the ID for .NET
application development,
and if you want to modernize your
application, using AWS Transform,
the first step
is to install.
The AWS took it,
so you are going to extension.
And search for AWS 2 kit with
Amazon Kill,
and this is the first step. You need
to have the extension installed
in Visual Studio ID.
With the
the plug-in, the station installed.
You will have the option to enable
AWS transform in IDE, and we
have a few options in here. If you
want to use only AWS Transform,
you can choose
the first option,
the option in the right side,
and we have the Amazon Q developer,
which now is the Quiro subscription
where you have the AWS transform and
plusative AI
options to help you modernize
your application.
So in this case for this demonstration, I will
use the Amazon Kill developer subscription.
OK,
With the extension.
Enabled
in Visual Studio.
In the right side
I have one solution here. It's a .NET
application. In here, I
have a project with .NET framework.
We can see here that it's the
version .NET framework
4.7.
And as we know,
the .NET framework is no longer
supported by Microsoft, and what I want to
achieve is to modernize this
application to .NET Core
version 8.
So how can I accomplish this?
In the Solution Explorer,
I right click in the solution,
and I have this option, Port solution
with AWS Transform.
Thank you.
And will ask me
what is the target
right now. We only support .NET
8, but soon we will support
.NET 10 as well.
And I will start the job transformation.
No. So
as we can see here,
the first thing,
your application needs to be in a state of
build, otherwise,
the transformation job will not start.
OK, now my, my application. er
Is building
and what is going to happen right
now. The AWS transform
will package all your source, source
code, the package required to your
application to execute,
and this source code will be sent
to uh AWS account, a sandbox.
Uh, it will create a um
a security connection with an AWS
account. It will send your search
code there.
And the transformation happens
in AWS account.
The transformation job doesn't
happen in your local computer.
So right now nothing changes in
your solution.
So the search the search code will
be analyzed
and transformed in
an AWS account.
And this process, it will take,
this is a small solution,
and this process, it will take like
15 to 20 minutes,
so I will not wait until the transformation
job. It's
done. I have one solution in here
that I already did this transformation.
And
when your source code
is transformed, when the job is done,
You will get the response in
the ID.
And this is how it looks like.
So in here, I have a summary of what
has changed,
the projects that I have,
in the,
in this uh part in here,
uh, in the bottom of the screen,
I can see.
That new files was added
in my solution.
So before I had
uh a web config in .NET Core.
I no longer need a web config.
Now I have app settings.
So the AWS transform
automatically added the files that
was missing
for .NET Core
application. So
all new files that I need to
have this application running on .NET
car is now available.
And files that are no longer
needed like Global ASA and other
files that are no longer in need,
the files was renamed.
And I can see there is some change
in my search code, and I can see the
change
that was done in my search
code. So
in here I can see uh some
half phrases
was replaced and some small
changes was done in my source
code. There
is a charge. And I
can download
the summary of everything that was
changed in my application
and see.
Um, all the changes
and the packages that uh
is changed or needs some
attention. So in the left side,
I have this Linux,
um, redness.
which demonstrate for this transformation.
The job was not able to
replace entity framework to entity
framework core,
so this is something that I need to
To change manually if I want to
make this application running or
to execute on .NET Core.
So with this report, I have an overview
of everything that was done in my
solution. So
as I said, right now, nothing
has changed in my solution.
So if I want to apply the chains that
the job did in my source
code, I need to select all the chains.
And apply the chains.
And since the project file was changed,
it's asking to reload the
solution. Now
I have, I have all the changes applied
in my solution. In the right side,
I can see now that I have the app settings,
the startup CS,
program CS, all the new files required
to have this application running, uh, to
run in .NET Core.
If I look in here,
The framework now is .NET 8,
so all the changes required to
this application to execute on .NET
on .NET.
8,
it's done now.
OK, this is the first step.
What about the changes that I mentioned that
I need to replace manually? OK,
my application,
now it's ready to work on .NET
.NET 8.
The has transformed jobs.
It doesn't
allow me to choose
more interactions or to interact with
the the transformation, so
it knows how,
how it works, the transformation, what needs to
replace, what needs to be changed,
but I don't have much more options
to interact with my source code. So
the only mission or the only goal
of AWS Transform
is to make your application available
in .NET 8.
If you have, if you need more interactions
with your source code,
we have another option in here.
Which is Amazon kill shed.
So this is a
This is the next step when you have your
application transformed.
So as I mentioned, I have tit framework.
And I need to change to entity framework
core.
So what I'm gonna do now is
ask
Amazon Killhat to replace.
Entity framework.
To Entity.
Framework
Core. So
this is very powerful because
he can access my search code, the
solution, understand what's happening with my
application. Read
the files
and replace
the files as needed.
So it's asking
to have access
to my solution.
I say yes.
Oh So
Oh. So
he knows that I need to execute some comments.
He knows what comments need to be executed
in my solution.
And we start to replace.
The packages,
the references.
And we will change as well
the source codes, my files
that need to be changed in order
to have the Entity Framework core.
Working in my solution.
And I can see all the changes
that he's making in my source
code. Yeah
So with these
two tools, AWS Transform
and Amazon Killhat,
I can interact with my source code,
add new classes,
ask to add new pages,
add new routes in my
application. All of this,
just typing what I want in
just uh
plain English.
So it's very powerful when we are, when
we are modernizing, or if you want to
understand, I'm a new developer, and I want to
understand what's going on with my application,
how the connection with database is uh
going on.
Uh, I can
debug my application,
fix errors, or just typing
the errors, uh, or message that I
want to,
the goal that I want to accomplish in the chat.
All of this without
Leaving the ID.
OK. And
this is the first step when we are talking
about modernizing our application.
It's not just moving from .NET
framework to .NET Core.
After this, if you want to accomplish
a more
performatic or reduced costs,
The next step
is to move our application
to execute on Graviton.
So now that we have our
application able to
run on Linux,
we can take advantage to
move our application to execute on
Graviton, and we did a performance
test with one application
and compared the cost of
this application running on a Windows
machine and then later converted
this application to run on an AMED.
And then comparing with Graviton,
you can see the cost
after modernize your application and
execute the same application on
Graviton, the cost difference is
huge.
And not only the costs.
The latest, the performance of this
application. It's much better.
So it's not only about to modernize
your application from .NET framework
to .NET Core. It will give you,
uh, it gives, give you
a better cost and a better
performance when executing on
a modern modern architecture.
So,
thank you, and now we have
Armando.
Say more words. Oh, thank you. Thank you,
Tiago,
and thanks everyone for listening to us.
Uh,
what's next for us?
Well, this was just the tip
of the iceberg of our migration
road map.
So basically we're going to continue
modernizing our net net
framework projects using the strangle fake
pattern. But now,
with what we have learned and reinvent,
we need to rethink this model, right?
We, we need to go further with Quiro
to accelerate the code development and modernization
as well. Uh,
of course we need to adopt a composable
serverless architecture to speed delivery
and boost efficiency,
so. And
of course we need to enhance
for the other features that we
have in our uh
payroll stamping services
we need to enhance the SQL database integrations
so perhaps we're going to migrate
from SQL server
to another.
Um,
Databases models.
So I just want to want to
end with the
with the.
Uh, this code, um,
it is not about migra
migrating your code, right?
You need to, to think broadly
and involve you,
uh, key members of your team,
and this time
we were able to, to work with
Mauricio, Roberto, and Pedro's
team, the architecture team,
and they got really involved in
this solutioning.
So we
can go farther
and deliver this on time and with the
expected results. So don't leave
your developers
alone on this.
And well, that's all from my
sight. Thank you.